and then when you take miles out you
move sabonis to five and you you brought
tj leaf in and there is a bonus with a
left hand
and now they will just use some clock
here's buddy healed
wow what a move by buddy hill lance
stevenson tonight leads indiana with ten
rebounds
good play
good play by victor oladipo zapona's got
a big stump
off of it
they're setting up for buddy here he is
now with griffin on him
buddy heel
to tie the game
[Applause]
yeah you got to push it though
stevenson does
leaves it off for sabonis who goes down
the lane oh yeah
oh yeah the pacers
down by 18. another big double figure
deficit
with a really good pass from victor
well he pushed he did dad young was
going to say something he pushed him in
the back
on the partisan bonus stevenson coast to
coast puts it up and in
tatum chases collison high screen set by
sabonis and booker
this is basketball that is best there
basketball at his best three-pointer
this first quarter for the warriors the
kings meanwhile if this goes that will
be their seventh yes
it does go buddy healed answering
draymond green
[Applause]
what a shot i mean oladipo was firing
him but he healed 13 seconds left
but he's the man off the bench with a
working on tucker
how about the using oz from the crowd
here in sacramento buddy hild has
learned how to create his shot
put inside knocked away once again
oladipo got a hand on it
oladipo sabonis swept the throw down
wow back into the swinger thing to go on
the road you know we as as you say we'd
like to rep yes
and that's tomas sabonis from victor
oladipo memphis had only 16 for the
entire game on wednesday
give it go oh yes
oh what a puncture that one
oh dumas the entire [ __ ] got up on that
one oh my goodness young man minnesota
the purpose is move the ball
they're very definitive also in what
they do and he will not be denied this
time yeah another big time screening
role there
a little pick and roll oh
he caught a body and it was in no good
long rebound
the elites in a body healed oh buddy
climbing the ladder and tramping it home
and a chance for one more
and especially a team that played last
night
right victor got one round away but
another pound there by some bonus
he's been the one guy for the magic
tonight they can knock it down from
outside whoa well the globetrotters are
coming into town is that one of the
globetrotters
racers 17 assists
comes right back with an answer
beautiful and once again it's darren
collison just navigating perfectly
the kings come to motown and they steal
the game
they steal the game
buddy hill
stuns the crowd here in detroit
[Applause]
72-58
oh what a move by buddy to set up
shumpert
well that goes back to what we're
talking about with buddy it's been
established and that makes things a lot
different as well
oh bonus again you wanted somebody to
get under there
[Applause]
sacramento
into the penis box
no good buddy heel though if you don't
like that you don't like nba basketball
but edmund sumner and alexa johnson have
rejoined the team they are both
dressed and active tonight
take it to the next level and be an
elite nba player
[Applause]
pushing his way to the rim and oh
you know i i think you can see all the
pieces grant left-handed mid-range
athletic enough to finish at the basket
go
buddy love up and under love
[Music]
[Applause]
yes he got him on that one embiid's down
here but pal took that lesson
went on a 17-2 run they outscored
philadelphia 38-16 in the second and put
it away
sabonis down the lane with authority
morris
grogged in the rebound 38 great pass
counts
no foul
yeah there it is they called it in late
there's a fall with that and the raptors
appear to be
putting another one in the win column
so bonus
and one
on the foul on ann and obi
barnes and joseph for sacramento
porter junior inbounds it to yogic
almost knocked away they get the steal
bars for the lead
couldn't punch it tipped up no
will it count
buddy
ball call
game run buddy run
they give it to sabonis he's gonna drive
to the basket
score to bow
to montessa bonus
shot clock at five wall
cutting is oh he got it yes a bonus got
him at the summit a summit meeting there
and defensively you can see that's where
they hang their hat
yeah you see it two seconds left tyrese
takes his time throws it up
tyreese knocks it down 125 109
foot by the pacers coming out of that
timeout and
doug just couldn't get it to go
at the rims bonus blocked it how about
that you don't see that very often
that too
he likes not to try and post up mannion
step back three on the way foul
counted let's go for four
smooth can't speed him up doug they
haven't been able to so far
whoa
halliburton
always with the timely bucket
yeah i don't want to watch too much of
it chris because
we came and got the rebound because it's
gonna work great pass this the bonus
sees every everybody moving gets it to
malcolm brogdon on the cut nearly threw
it away damien jones back to harrison
barnes shot clock down to six
buddy three
again
a lot of movement kd side to side
making five rebounds keep ticking on it
then
buddy
from folsom
yes sir
buddy healed with the three
[Music]
[Applause]
and now the screen comes a little
two-man game with holiday to turn it
over
but he's got a little bit of time
launches
[Applause]
and there they have never taken the foot
off the pedal tonight
oh really good pass
i mean that's a one-handed bounce pass
by jeremy lamb
inbound to buddy
westbrook grabbing fox buddy off one leg
got it buddy buckets does it again